الحرب المشتعله في السودان يمكن ان يتطاير
لها الى دول الجوار تدرك هذه الدول هذه
الحقيقه وتعرف ان ما يحدث يهدد الاستقرار
في المنطقه مصر الجار الشمالي حدد وزير
خارجيه اسامح شكري موقفها في ثلاث نقاط
ضروره التواصل مع طرفي النزاع لحقن دماء
السودانيين ضروره التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار في اقرب وقت ممكن ضروره التعامل مع
النزاع القائم كشان داخلي تشير النقطه
الاخيره الى مخاوف من تدخلات اجنبيه تطيل
النزاع وتعقد الحل مع ما يتبع ذلك من
تاثير في الامن الاقليمي هذه المخاوف عبرت
عنها الجاره الجنوبيه اثيوبيا التي شهدت
علاقاتها مع السودان توترا ملحوظا في
الاونه الاخيره بسبب نزاعات حدوديه حذر
رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا ابي احمد من اي
محاولات ذات دوافع واجندات خفيه للتدخل في
الشان السوداني تسعى لتدمير مقدرات البلاد
حسب تعبيره دوله جنوب السودان التي كان
يشاركون السودانيين البلد الواحد قبل
الانقسام تعيش مشكلات داخليه كثيره ويعرف
ساستها ان هذه المشكلات ستتعقد اكثر اذا
استمر النزاع في السودان رئيسها العرض
وساطه في اطار منظمه
مع رؤساء دول اخرى بالمنطقه زياره قريبه
للخرطوم لكن الحرب الدائره هناك حالت دون
ذلك في تشاد التي يبلغ طول حدودها مع
السودان اكثر من 1400 كيلومتر قالت
الحكومه انها اغلقت حدودها مع السودان
وناشدت المجتمع الاقليمي والدولي وكذلك
جميع الدول الصديقه منحى الاولويه لعوده
السلام كما اعلن وزير دفاعها عن استقبال
مئات الجنود السودانيين الذين دخلوا
اراضيها اما ليبيا التي دفعت ايضا ثمن
تطاحن بين ابناء البلد الواحد فوضعها
الداخلي بدا واضحا في رد فعلها وزيره
خارجيه في الحكومه الوحده الوطنيه نجلاء
المنقوش عبرت عن استعداد بلادها لاداء دور
الوساطه ودعت الى الاستجابه للنداءات التي
تطالب بوقف الاش فورا وتغليب لغه الحوار
بين الاشقاء تدعو المنقوش لتغذيب لغه
الحوار وتنقل صحيفه الامريكيه عن مصادر ان
اللواء الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ارسل
طائره واحده على الاقل لنقل امدادات
عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع في السودان لا
يمكن فصل موقف دول الجوار عن موقف اطراف
دوليه اخرى تسعى لاستغلال الصراع في
السودان لكن دول الجوار هي التي ستدفع
الثمن بعد السودانيين اذا تعقد النزاع
والصعصى على الحل